okay so number one I am sick I am really
frickin sick at this moment and I'm
sitting here in front of these giant
lights in front of this camera I went
and I saw Kung Fu Panda 3 with a ton of
tissues in my hand and I'm here to talk
about it because movies I'm gonna do my
best let's go with Kung Fu Panda 3 we
now have a trilogy I've enjoyed the
previous two movies I think they're fun
harmless entertainment there's not a lot
of substance but they're really
enjoyable movies with a lot of fun
action and great animation and in this
movie PO played by Jack Black meets his
actual father played by Bryan Cranston
and he discovers there's a secret panda
village all the while there's this crazy
guy named Kai who's after the power of
all the kung fu masters who are still
alive and it's up to PO & tigress and
monkey and all of them as well as the
new panda village to go up against this
guy to stop him from defeating the
entire world this movie was odd for me
because it's January and usually
animated films that come out this time
of year are really bad like norm of the
north oh my god but this movie was
originally going to come out on December
23rd of last year but they pushed it
back to January because of Star Wars not
wanting to compete with that and this
movie was tons of fun I might have
actually liked this one more than the
last it's a very fast paced movie there
really are no dull moments in Kung Fu
Panda 3 and sometimes that does bring on
a lack of substance where you don't feel
like there's much emotional heft going
on in the movie even though there is a
good storyline involving Poe's father as
well as his adoptive father and how that
becomes a little odd for him because
he's had the same father his whole life
and now he has his actual father
suddenly returned and he has to learn
how to deal with that and similar to the
other two Kung Fu Panda movies this one
is once again about him discovering
something about himself that he didn't
know he was capable of and it maintains
that same theme and yes they're all very
similar and even though they all have a
very similar storyline they're all fun
movies and I think they're really good
for kids because they'd also don't
pander to children there's a good story
underneath all the action and the jokes
about family and I think kids can really
take something away from it I also loved
Hans Zimmer's score especially his theme
for Kai the main villain this movie was
tons and tons of fun
I was very sick when I went to this
movie and I smiled throughout the entire
thing despite having to blow my nose
every couple seconds as for flaws as I
said the movie doesn't really have a
whole lot of substance there is a good
story involving family and how important
that is but it's kind of overshadowed by
the jokes in the action which isn't
necessarily a fault it's just that the
movie does come off a little bit
weightless no pun intended it's just
kind of like disposable but it's great
fun so I can't really fault the film for
that even though I left the theater not
feeling like I had that much of an
emotional experience this is Kung Fu
Panda 3 do I really need that not really
I had a great time with this movie
despite being sick and I bet if I wasn't
sick I would have had a even better time
I'm gonna give Kung Fu Panda 3 and a -
so I apologize for this brief review but
my voice is already leaving me
gratefully I already filmed my
Dragonball Evolution hilarious 'ti
review you can see the stuff that I use
I can barely say that name you can see
the background I had for it and that's
gonna go up on Sunday here is a little
teaser I put together for you
[Music]
oh that movie is movie has to go away
guys let me know if you saw Kung Fu
Panda 3 and what you thought of it below
thank you so much as always for watching
I will try to get my review up for Jane
got a gun in the next few days I still
haven't seen it yet I barely got out of
the house with this cold but anyway
thank you once again guys for watching
and if you liked this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]
[Applause]